the aeroverse contains a vast wealth of
heroes
but every shining knight has a weakness
these are the weaknesses of the arrow
versus best
and brightest from their debilitating
phobias to their reckless attitudes
beth chapel just wants to be long while
she loves her parents
she also resents them a little as they
stopped paying much attention to her
once she grew old enough to take care of
herself
as a result this young genius gloms onto
courtney whitmore and yolanda montez
when she realizes that they are forming
some kind of secret
club upon learning their superheroes she
gets even more excited
once courtney realizes that beth has
somehow managed to activate dr
midnight's artificial intelligence
goggles
she allows her to join the new justice
society however her clingy nature and
desperate desire to prove herself
leads her to make mistakes and act
impulsively
rick tyler was raised by his uncle matt
unbeknownst to him
his father rex was the hero hourman rex
and his wife were murdered by solomon
grundy though rick was told they died in
a car crash
as a result rick rose up angry
alienating everyone around him
when courtney whitmore reveals to him
that his father had been our man
and beth chapel shows him the truth of
his death he decides to turn his anger
on the injustice society
this anger makes him undisciplined and
sloppy eventually he decides to act for
justice
instead of revenge however a lifetime of
feeling abandoned still makes anger his
first response to stress
yolanda montez has great grades
popularity
a likely win in the upcoming student
election and a boyfriend when he
pressures her to send him a nude photo
however he shares it with everyone
humiliating her in front of the whole
school
worse her parents feel that she's
disgraced them and stopped taking her to
church
it takes a persistent courtney whitmore
to convince her to become wildcat and
join her new
justice society still it takes yolanda
a long time to work through her shame
for quite a while she pushes everyone
away
in time she learns to do things for the
right reasons but part of her will
always miss the life she once had
the fact that she can never return to it
hauntzer
when those photos got around
i was ashamed to be yolanda montez renee
ramirez starts his career as a vigilante
with sloppy working methods
joining team arrow is an adjustment for
everyone because he isn't used to
working as part of a team and definitely
isn't used to following orders he chafes
at oliver queen's rigid leadership
style and constantly blows up this makes
him a major liability
it isn't until much later that he learns
how to calm down and not take everything
so personally
his passion to do the right thing is his
greatest asset but when that passion
boils over he's a weak link in the field
john spartan diggle is a man who is
constantly trying to figure out his next
step
he's been a soldier a bodyguard and
eventually a member of team arrow
as important as he is to the cause he is
always in oliver's shadow
this dissatisfaction eats at him no
matter how much he loves oliver
everything changes when oliver decides
to retire for a while
leaving his role to diggle being green
arrow clearly means the world to him so
when oliver takes the role back
diggle is devastated his need to be
something more than he is
causes him to leave team arrow and move
over to argus
but that role doesn't suit him either it
isn't until the end of the series
which implies that he has chosen to be
the new green lantern
that he finds his place curtis holt is
an olympic decathlete a genius engineer
and an academic possessing 14 different
degrees
initially serving as part of team
arrow's support crew he's beaten up by
thugs and vows to never be put in that
position again
he learns hand-to-hand combat and
becomes fairly good at it but never
quite catches up to his teammates
moreover ptsd often makes him hesitate
in combat he later struggles with anger
at oliver queen for putting all new
members under surveillance the
dissolution
of his marriage because of his double
life and his distaste for argus's
tactics
eventually curtis quits the life but
remains available for research and
intelligence
thea queen starts out much like her
brother a privileged partier who gets
mixed
up with a lot of bad people when she
learns that oliver's arch enemy malcolm
merlin
is her actual father her life is
appended
merlin trains her to become a killer
using league of assassin's methods
she turns on him in time and becomes a
member of team arrow
but dies later on she is revived by the
last wrist pit
but it gives her an insatiable bloodlust
once she is cured of this
she takes a job in oliver queen's
merrell office and makes some ethically
dubious moves
no matter what thea does she always goes
too far
and rarely considers the consequences of
her actions
eventually she retires from all kinds of
vigilante activity and public life
roy harper credits oliver with giving
him purpose after a hard start in life
but poor roy suffers as a result of
becoming a crime fighter
being kidnapped and injected with serum
that boosts his abilities at the cost of
his mental stability
while he eventually receives an antidote
he is later killed and resurrected by
the bloodlust
inducing lazarus pit he receives the
special lotus formula to counteract this
effect
but the lingering influence of the serum
continues to urge him towards violence
only by leaving the vigilante life
altogether can he control
it after gaining sonic powers detective
dinah drake embarks
upon a violent campaign of revenge on
the criminal she believes killed her
partner
eventually oliver queen convinces her to
join team arrow
she ultimately finds herself torn
between various allegiances
especially after discovering that the
murderous vigilante
is in fact her ex-partner and
ex-boyfriend she keeps this a secret
which is a major breach of trust
later she mr terrific and wild dog break
away from team arrow
after discovering they've been put under
surveillance she is made chief of police
which puts her allegiance to the law
breaking team arrow
in jeopardy dinah is forced to betray
the trust of either the police force
team arrow or both when she travels to
the future after oliver queen's funeral
she gives up the adventurer's life for a
long time as a result
laurel lance of earth 2 wasn't lucky
enough to have a loving father around to
raise her
she drifts through life until she gains
her sonic scream at which point
she signs up with zoom to help her try
to conquer earth 1.
she causes further trouble assisting the
likes of prometheus and ricardo diaz
but quentin lance earth 1 laurel's
father never gives up on her
eventually she becomes a force for good
her biggest flaw is her urge to ignore
her newly developed conscience
old habits die hard after all instead of
blaming others
she works hard to take her father's love
and faith in her to heart
even though she is constantly tempted to
backslide
ray palmer is a genius but perhaps more
importantly
he's the moral compass of the legends
but his kind and gentle nature can be
a liability he is not a natural fighter
and so he is not the guy who is going
to battle to his last breath to save the
day indeed he prefers sitting down with
his enemies
in the hopes of persuading them to
change their minds rather than fight
them
this makes him a decent person but not
always the best superhero
his deciding to leave the group in order
to start a new life with nora makes a
lot of sense
as much as he enjoys hanging out with
his friends he's not a lifelong soldier
mick rory becomes a criminal because he
hates authority he also struggles with
guilt over the death of his parents who
perished in a blaze he set
as a child when he agrees to become a
legend it's because he wants to steal a
bunch of stuff while time traveling
while he betrays the team more than once
he eventually settles back
and has a cornerstone of the crew albeit
one with a room full of stolen riches
after he changes a timeline and
accidentally fathers a daughter
mick finds himself with mixed emotions
he doesn't want the responsibility of
fatherhood but also doesn't want his
daughter to go
through life without a dad this proves
to be the one thing he can't ignore
while he is warming to the role of
parent he is wary of the responsibility
he now shoulders
come on i'm trying
all right what is our father-daughter
weekend gonna look like
ava sharp is recruited by rip hunter to
work for his time bureau
in order to protect the timeline with a
rigid set of rules
she's all about rigid rules and loves
her role in running the bureau
until she learns the horrible truth
about her past she's a clone who has had
her memories wiped
which were replaced with fake ones she
is later forced to fight clones of
herself
which does a number on her identity
while she finds a home with the legends
and the love of her life sarah lance
ava is still sensitive about being a
clone and thus not a real person
my my life my memories they're all
manufactured
they're they're not real i'm not even
real ava you are real
john constantine pretends to be above it
all in large part this is because he's
brought grief and pain to those around
him
what's worse his guilt with regard to
hard choices that he's had to make
has led him to make even worse choices
in an effort to fix
things for example when he tries to
alter the timeline to prevent his
boyfriend from being dragged off to hell
it just makes the ensuing timeline more
bizarre
zari gets turned into a cat and the team
is turned into puppets
trying to assuage his guilt on his own
only makes things worse for everyone but
it also makes him even more afraid of
relying on others
whether it's amaya g wei or her
granddaughters mari and kuwasa
filling the role the heroine known as
vixen is always bound to defend zambezi
village with the anansi totem
amaya does spend time away from her
tribe as vixen during world war ii when
she joins the justice society
and then joins the time spanning legends
but she knows that her time there is
limited as she must return to zambezi
after the timeline has changed mari and
kawasa decide to share the anansi totem
growing up in solidarity instead of as
enemies
however no matter where they go or what
they do their allegiance to their
village and their willingness to do
whatever it takes to save it makes this
a permanent area of vulnerability a
shape-shifter charlie has a serious
hatred of authority and a general
distrust of others
eons ago she was clavo one of the three
mythological fates
she decides to break the loom that gave
her and her sister's control over mortal
lives however
she's been on the run from her sisters
atrophos and leukesis ever since
even when she's with the legends she is
guarded about her past and doesn't trust
them
enough to tell them her secrets coming
clean might have prevented a lot of
grief as the other two fates eventually
catch up with her
in many ways nora dark is the most
unlikely legend of all
the daughter of their enemy damien dark
her parents died when they tried to
destroy most of the world and one of
damien's schemes
she is later connected to a cult and
enslaved by the demon malice in an
effort to resurrect
him she is severely scarred and
traumatized by the experience
despite all of this ray palmer shows her
nothing but kindness
seeing only the good in her when damien
sees this he sacrifices his own life to
save his daughters
nora's time as a fairy godmother allows
her to work through some of her
childhood trauma but it takes embarking
on a new life with
reyes wife and leaving the legends
behind to truly heal
nate haywood is a big nerdy kid who gets
to use his knowledge of historical data
to have the biggest adventure of his
life
he loves his friends and will do
anything for them nate
ray and bayrod form a sort of sub
fraternity and
legends goofing around together and
exchanging many high fives
but this endearing quality of nades is
also his weakness as he can be
emotionally manipulated in the same way
a kid can
not having a father who showed him love
means that he searches constantly
for outside approval and often makes
poor decisions based on his feelings
fortunately for him he has the legends
to keep him grounded
mona wu is sweet and naive but that
niceness conceals a nasty violent temper
she doesn't just get angry she has
tantrums
this impulsiveness is what gets her
mixed up with the legends in the first
place
when she is scratched by a werewolf-like
creature called akape she is transformed
into one herself
suddenly when she gets mad she turns
into her wolfy form
and is perfectly happy to attack both
friends and foe alike
anyone who triggers a tantrum is fair
game which makes her more than a little
unstable as a teammate
when the legends change the timeline in
zari tomas is replaced by her brother
bayrod
it means that she suddenly disappeared
into the air totem this is where the
spirits of its former wielders live
but zari the adventurer never existed in
the new timeline
instead there is zari tarazzi the highly
pampered social media influencer
this sari accidentally discovers her
brother is a superhero
and starts hanging out with the team as
she learns about her other self and
realizes that flashes of her abilities
have started to bubble up in her
she stays with the legends however she
is still self-important
arrogant and high maintenance she's just
aggressive enough to get away with it
but there are definitely times she's
tolerated more than loved
when the timeline is altered zarya's
brother bayrod terrazzi becomes the heir
totem bearing member
of the legends on a team of slackers and
degenerates bayrod
still stands out as the most mellow
member of the legends with a supremely
laid-back personality
he's a little too relaxed at times in
fact
as he doesn't always take things as
seriously as he needs to
for him these missions aren't life and
death but a spirited adventure he's glad
to be taking
this attitude can be nice to be around
but it also makes him hard to depend on
leo snart is a freedom fighter from the
nazi ruled earth x
after meeting the legends he decides to
briefly join the team and hang out on
earth 1.
quite unlike his earth 1 counterpart
this leo is meticulous and hates the
legends sloppy ways
he particularly chastises rory for using
his flamethrower indiscriminately
he doesn't stay with the legends for
very long and though the reasons why
aren't related to his particular ways he
likely knows he's too fastidious to be a
long-term fit
with this group of misfits james olson
is tired of feeling left out that's why
he becomes the armored guardian
however after james is shot lena luther
injects him with the kryptonian har and
l serum james gains actual kryptonian
superpowers and loses control of them
when he struggles with ptsd related
panic attacks
with professional help he is able to get
through this and in time his system
is purged of the serum but the trauma of
the experience is often triggered by
hearing gunshots or simply seeing lex
luthor
is something he will always have to
manage nia takes up the mantle of
dreamer after her mother
the previous dreamer dies nia is an
intense perfectionist and her own worst
critic
this is exacerbated by her imperfect
control of her precognitive
and dream related powers which leads her
to misunderstand that her mother is
going to die
nia has a lot to live up to as dreamer
and she knows it putting too much
pressure on herself
as a result however she slowly overcomes
this as she becomes more confident and
learns to
ask for help manel and kara are an
unlikely couple but their bond is real
tragically they are separated when he is
forced to go to the 31st century for his
own safety
there he founds the legion and mary's
fellow member emra
when they go back in time and he finds
himself face to face with kara
he tries to put her off but it's not
long before he realizes that he is still
in love with her this starts to affect
his judgment his marriage
and even the foundations of his heroism
he bases too much of himself on her
and eventually returns to the 31st
century because he knows he has to
putting the greater good
above his own desires jon jones hates
fire which scares him so badly
it affects his shape-shifting however
what haunts him
even more deeply is survivor's guilt he
believes himself to be the last of the
green martians who were wiped out in a
genocide perpetrated by the white
martians
even though he's since learned that his
younger brother and father are alive
jon never recovers from the death of his
wife and children he still feels guilty
for living while they cannot
enemies often exploit this [ __ ] in his
armor through the use of psychic attacks
quarrel doxx is a tactical genius an
efficient fighter and an all-around
powerhouse of digital might however he's
wary of his ancestry being born
into the brainiac clan descendants of
one of superman's most relentless
enemies
kind-hearted brainy worries that evil
lurks within him as well and not without
cause
he is cut off from his emotions when his
mind is rebooted
only regaining them and his sense of
empathy when he sees the love of his
life nia now
in danger anissa pierce is a brilliant
young medical student
part-time teacher and community activist
her strong ideals are backed up by her
courage
and steely resolve when she realizes
that she has superpowers
she keeps them hidden so she can figure
out what she is capable of
in private still she is reckless and
attacking the various gangs that plague
freeland
when her father finally gives her his
blessing in exchange for working as a
team she makes fewer mistakes in the
field
of course she then concocts an entirely
new persona blackbird that robs from
gangs and gives money to the church and
needy people
she just can't help being a loose cannon
jennifer pierce never wanted superpowers
but she gets them anyway
as she's not a natural fighter like her
father and sister she tries to minimize
their effect upon her life
her powers just can't be denied however
when she tries to not use them
they build up and cause her intense pain
unlike jefferson who is something of a
battery
jyn is a generator this means that she
can do pretty much anything her dad can
but isn't at risk of running out of
juice
accepting her powers come slowly to her
but fighting for her family
makes it possible cisco ramon is an
integral part of team flash as a hacker
leader and tech guy but being betrayed
by his mentor who is actually the
reverse flash makes cisco distrustful of
everyone
that even includes his best friend barry
allen as he creates a weapon to stop him
just in case he turns evil goes insane
or otherwise loses control of his powers
this approach means ramon is always a
little on edge with everyone even as he
projects an easygoing friendly demeanor
after being introduced to the nasty
killer frost of earth 2
and realizing that her ex-lover is
actually the murderous zoom
caitlyn snow slowly starts to feel her
long dormant second personality
emerge when her other side takes over
she is every bit as vicious as her earth
2 counterpart
however the love shown to her by members
of team flash allows both caitlyn and
killer frost to co-exist
taking turns driving still this
relationship with her other self has its
ups and downs
when her two sides quarrel or don't feel
they're getting enough time
driving caitlyn gets more than a little
unstable
when ralph bibney first receives his
powers he's a private detective
he works as a pi because he was
disgraced as a cop having planted false
evidence
when he becomes a hero and starts taking
barry allen's lessons and example to
heart he legitimately changes his ways
and stops cutting moral corners
i don't do that kind of stuff anymore
ralph didn't he's gone straight
you serious i got friends now they're
good people
however ralph's icky personality endorse
especially when it comes to dealing with
women his romantic
advice to others is like something out
of a pickup artist handbook
what's more even as ralph has gained
humility in many ways he still sees
himself as a font of wisdom
he's just too in love with his own
patter to take a hard look
in the mirror wally west is one of the
most
unsettled heroes in the arrowverse
having grown up in dysfunctional
circumstances
he struggles with tension and jealousy
when he gains his own super speed he is
reckless and a bit of a glory hog
he is so overjoyed to have superpowers
in fact that he starts to use them for
the wrong reasons
though he eventually comes to terms with
his anger and jealousy
he leaves central city he just never
manages to feel like he fits in
he goes off to find himself in a
buddhist monastery and is later
convinced to join the legends
wally makes some friends but eventually
quits that too
kid flash could be an all-star superhero
but his lack of direction
holds him back in many ways kate kane
is a better superhero than her cousin
bruce wayne she's more flexible in her
thinking and more willing to ask for
help
furthermore she is a steadying force
when she becomes the paragon of courage
during the crisis
however the return of her seemingly dead
twin sister beth as the psychotic
criminal alice reportedly leads batwoman
to make major mistakes
kate captures and lets her go on more
than one occasion despite her homicidal
ways
the survivor's guilt kate feels over the
fact that she stopped looking for beth
years earlier
is simply more than she can bear as a
result more than one person she cares
about is murdered and kate has to deal
with knowing that they'd likely be alive
if she'd had more resolve as you likely
know
superman's biggest physical weakness is
green kryptonite which is lethal
in large enough doses furthermore red
kryptonite turns him evil
and silva kryptonite makes him
hallucinate he's also vulnerable to
magic and mind control however
his real weakness is the love of his
life lois lane
and his adoptive parents martha and
jonathan kent
he's terrified of enemies learning about
them and now he's frightened that
something will happen to his new baby
this doesn't stop him from doing the
right thing but enemies who know
anything about
him know to strike adam through his
family lex luthor his archenemy
knows this most keenly of all when
courtney whitmore discovers the cosmic
staff
among her stepfather's belongings
everything changes
the staff allows her to bond with it to
become star girl
and she sets about forming a new justice
society despite her stepfather's
warnings
overeager courtney makes a lot of
mistakes with her recklessness
even getting people killed she thinks
that having powers on her own team
will somehow solve everything without
considering that the original justice
society
also had their own powers and were still
murdered by their enemies
while she eventually calms down a little
with regard to leading the new jsa
she still tends to act without thinking
things through
jefferson pierce's paternalistic
attitude doesn't just affect his family
but the people he works with as well
in thinking he knows how to protect
everyone best he often makes unilateral
decisions that don't respect the agency
of his super-powered daughters his
highly capable wife his students
and even his allies in the freeland
police department
it takes him a long time to figure out
that people are going to do what they
want to do
and that he has to cooperate the irony
of this
is that as a school principal his whole
job is trying to find ways to empower
young people
as a superhero he doesn't do that enough
sarah lance starts off as a party girl
who has an affair with her sister
laurel's boyfriend
oliver queen after their ill-fated yacht
trip she does what she has to do
to survive she helps torture people
aboard the amazo
joins the league of assassins and
becomes a trained killer
eventually she breaks away to become a
vigilante
though she dies she is resurrected but
her reanimated body lacks a soul which
leads to her
becoming a killing machine even when her
soul is reunited with her body she is
haunted by the
rage inside of her that she often can't
control nora dark is eventually able to
help her with this
but it doesn't erase her past of all the
heroes in the arrowverse
kara danvers is surely the nicest she's
a kind compassionate
and loving person who works well on her
own and is part of a larger team
she's also willing to see the good in
nearly everyone which can be a liability
you can't blame her too much how would
you handle birth parents who invent
horrifying technology designed to murder
and or enslave people
her adoptive father jeremiah danvers
isn't much better
he is a double agent who uses cars
trusting nature to hide his betrayal
her naivete has faded after these
experiences
and she's become more battle-hardened
and confident but she is still the
paragon of hope and while that's very
much a strength this optimism
is often used against her barry allen's
inherent decency
is his greatest strength it makes him a
wonderful friend
a great team member and a stalwart hero
however
once barry makes up his mind about
something it is impossible to get him to
change
course he'd rather learn by catastrophic
example
than accept the wisdom of others that's
especially true if the stakes
are personal the trauma of seeing his
parents killed
unhinges him to the point where he
alters the timeline
inadvertently changing the lives of
everyone he loves
and not always for the better he
frantically tries to fix this mess but
things never quite return to normal
it takes earth 2's flash jay garrick to
teach him that he simply has to let it
go
barry mostly avoids mucking with the
timeline following this crisis
but not entirely oliver queen thinks
that he knows best for everyone and
rarely deviates from acting on this
belief
he is enormously distrustful conceals
secrets and openly lies in the name of
protecting his loved ones
this alienates much of team arrow and
nearly destroys his relationship with
felicity smoke
admittedly his unilateral
decision-making does save the universe
oliver sacrifices himself in order to
create the new earth prime
and resurrects billions of lives it's
almost as though he knows his form of
leadership
is no longer viable in this new world he
can't change his domineering ways
and so he makes one final sweeping
choice that takes him out of the
equation
check out one of the newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite aeroverse characters
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you